foreign
so this little machine
this one right here that I could hold in
my hands
has more power than a base Mac Pro right
now more CPU power anyway now I hope
that that's not true for much longer
because the Mac Pro is overdue for its
Apple silicon upgrade but the fact that
it's true at all right now is absolutely
insane this little machine is not only
super powerful and super efficient and
super small
but it's also a really good price so I
said my last video about the MacBook
Pros that the Mac Mini is actually the
more interesting machine and I mean it
it really is it's just gotten a refresh
from the M1 chip that it had before to
now having an M2 and an M2 Pro option
both of which are kind of game changers
in their own ways so first the M2
version the base M2 Mac Mini is a game
changer because it's it's all the
benefits of the new Apple silicon stuff
the second generation five nanometer
process the Blazing fast shared memory
all the optimizations that come with it
for a starting price of 599 U.S so I
mean it's a pretty simple computer not
even a small Tower just an absolutely
tiny computer in there it's basically
the laptop but without the screen and
the keyboard only one color silver and
then a decent selection of ports around
the back along with a small exhaust vent
for active Cooling and a headphone jack
and so this thing packs a surprisingly
enormous power for its size we've seen
this apple silicon trends play out over
the past two years and when the Mac Mini
moved to Apple silicon from the Intel
chips it took an absolutely hilarious
leap up in performance some of the
numbers on paper are just ridiculous you
have to forgive me for using Apple's
stupid unlabeled charts but like just to
give you an idea this completely changed
the nature of the product so this M1 Mac
Mini is already dramatically better than
the Intel one for 99 of people and now
the M2 comes along with more cores a
more powerful CPU and GPU more max
memory and a higher overall performance
ceiling and the price goes down from
6.99 to 5.99 Apple almost never lowers
the price of the entry level of anything
but that's exactly what's happened here
so we just got a computer that's more
powerful and more capable and more
efficient
for less money and so then we also have
the M2 Pro Mac Mini this is the one that
I've been testing and using and so
before we just had the base Apple
silicon M1 Mac Mini now that's the M2
but we've also now got this Pro chip
which raises the ceiling for Mac Mini
performance still on the same tiny body
well actually I can't say the exact same
tiny body because the M2 pro version
also does gain two more Thunderbolt
ports so now there's four Thunderbolt 4
ports on the back along with everything
else still here and that means you can
now do three external displays instead
of two and you can still option up to 10
gigabit Ethernet if you're blessed with
that type of internet connection or if
you're at an institution that will take
advantage of the networking capability
and yes that is HDMI 2.1 but the big
deal here with this new chip is the M2
Pro is so much more performant thanks to
the updated architecture and the extra
cores that it's now benchmarking
actually over the M1 Pro and the M1 Max
in the CPU Department that was in the
highest end MacBook Pros before I to
Double Take when I first read that
because M1 Max has been so incredible
but yet here we are even the incremental
improvements here are notable and on top
of that the thermal Advantage
potentially of a Mac Mini with active
Cooling in a taller chassis over a
MacBook Pro can also mean in the long
term you know sustained CPU performance
over time you may see even better
results there so this thing's
performance is Rock Solid and then of
course as you move up in chips from base
to Pro to Max that's actually mostly a
GPU Improvement and so M2 Pro does great
here too but as you can see the results
fall sort of more online it's
Improvement of course over the last one
but the max chips are still the way to
go if your application specifically take
advantage of GPU power but then everyday
performance is just it's going to be the
same which is to say great but the
sustained multi-core performance ceiling
is just way higher you know especially
for things like video editing or app
development things that have basically
longer compile times or render times
that might be above what you want to do
on the base m to that's awesome on the
M2 Pro this model starts at 12.99 not
cheap of course but when you consider
the M2 Pro MacBook Pro with the exact
same system on a chip starts at 19.99
right now
pretty good that's actually that's the
real reason I'm calling these Mac minis
a game changer or at least for being so
good is performance per dollar you don't
usually expect that out of a Mac but if
I were to do like one of those dumb
Apple charts of like here's the laptop's
performance per dollar and then here's
the Mac minis which is the same
performance but for less money it's
better the line's higher you know for so
long Apple's prioritize these laptops
which makes perfect sense by the way
they've been great lots of people buy
them but some people get the laptop and
then just keep it in one room all the
time because desktop options aren't as
appealing and for being honest the iMac
is cool but it's not for everyone like
even right now it kind of feels like
apple low-key forgot about the iMac it's
just been sitting with the unupgraded M1
chip for a little while now even when M2
is out but then they dropped Mac Studio
and Max studio is excellent in the
highest end configurations and I can't
wait for the M2 Ultra here but yeah the
Mac Mini now slots in really nicely
underneath all of that and of course
with the modularity of a desktop that
doesn't come with a monitor built in now
you pick whatever display you want with
the 700 you save it's funny in recent
reviews I've been trying to give
sustainability notes where it's relevant
and so there are some neat ones with
this machine like recycled aluminum the
the packaging on the outside the
Recycled Plastics on the inside of the
Mac all that's cool but all of that sort
of is outweighed by the ability to
continue using your same display and
swap out displays however you want
unlike the iMac call me crazy but I
think there's a lot of people who
probably don't want to be stuck with a
non-upgradable display and webcam and
white bezels forever plus if you already
have a display you like yeah you can
just continue using that I haven't done
a video on the Mac Mini since the
fastest Mac Mini in the world project
that I did back in college uh shout out
to those of you who subscribed back then
but I basically I took the highest and
available Mac Mini in 2012 and Max It
Out by upgrading to the fastest Ram the
fastest SSD it would support in an
effort to make get like the most capable
tiny machine for a college dorm room
where space is at a premium because
clearly my priorities at the time were
video editing over homework now this M2
Pro Mac Mini has all the power that I
would have killed for back then as a
fledgling creator with not a lot of
space and it costs less it costs less I
had to look back I spent in total with
the mac and all the upgrades
1759 for the fastest Mac Mini in the
world
this one blows it out the water as far
as performance and capability of course
the difference here is no part of this
tightly integrated machine is upgradable
at all so now you got to think about
spending a little bit more to account
for having the machine for a long time
and not upgrading things maybe a little
more RAM maybe a little more storage
depends on what you're doing with it but
yeah this this would have blown out the
water this can handle basically any
footage that I could possibly throw at
it that I could shoot myself also by the
way if you actually do happen to be
looking at one of these and you are in
college like I was back then don't
forget about the student discount that's
typically 100 bucks off and I think with
these machines it's 100 bucks so now
that brings this down 100 that also
brings the base M2 down to 4.99 which is
great so in conclusion if you're trying
to think of if you're trying to pick one
Mac to buy right now think of it this
way if you already have an apple silicon
Mac like an M1 generation Mac you're
good you don't have to buy a new Mac
every year those machines were a great
update over the Intel ones you're set
now if you have an older machine and
you're actually looking to upgrade I
would actually default volt to the Mac
Mini and just start with the base M2 599
Mac Mini and I would not buy the iMac
right now because if you look at the
specs specifically it's still M1 and
it's 12.99 for a non-removable 24 inch
display I would just get the Mac Mini
instead and get whatever 600 screen you
want you can swap that out however so I
wouldn't recommend iMac right now and
then if you know that you specifically
want to be Computing on the go that's
when you move over UK okay the laptops
are really good you can get an M2
generation MacBook Pro and those are
excellent I just reviewed them if you
want to check it out links below the
like button that video is up and that's
how I think about the lineup but
honestly if you can find an M1
generation MacBook Pro right now on a
discount that's really good too and then
within each lineup of course I keep
saying this but the big difference
between M2 M2 Pro M2 Max and eventually
M2 Ultra when it comes out is GPU so it
shouldn't be a shock that they're all
sort of similar in CPU performance but
if the applications that you use and you
know your workflow will take advantage
of GPU power
then that's when you bump that up
okay yeah that's pretty much it maybe a
little bit shocking but yeah price for
performance Mac Mini kind of a huge
winner Mac Mini might make me miss
removable memory but it makes most
massive media machines feel pretty mid
thanks for watching
catch you guys in the next one peace
[Music]